hello everyone and welcome to the game
you've all been waiting for it is round
five of the London chess classic and we
have Michael Adams versus top seed of
the tournament GES who has to win the
tournament in order to qualify for the
FED candidates tournament 2024 his
opponent Michael Adams the most
unpleasant one uh against anyone he's
having an incredible tournament uh let's
see what happened in this one so uh
Michael has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 gkes goes for C5 saying
that he's very much interested in a
fight
Knight F3 we have Knight to C6 and now
Bishop to B5 going for Dan medino rosimo
attack we have Pawn to E6 castles and
Knight G to E7 uh we have Rook to E1 and
now A6 and Knight to D4 are the main
ideas here but Gish goes for Pawn to B6
and it's a very rare move uh been played
maybe maybe 40 times and okay out of the
stronger players only magnet and Fabiano
corana have used it but not in classical
chest they only used it in Blitz Blitz
Games so gkes obviously prepared
something strong if he is he if he's um
prepared to use it in a classical game
Pawn to C3 A6 now attacking the bishop
Bishop to A4 and pawn to C4 now stopping
the advancement of the D Pawn uh but not
really as Michael just plays Pawn to D4
so Z captures on D3 alasa Queen captures
and now we have Knight to G6 there are
some games where B5 was played also
Queen to C7 is a know move but after
Knight to uh G6 it is now as of move n
that we have a completely new game so
okay Knight to D4 hoping that Gish
captures and Michael gets to improve his
Pawn structure in the center of the
board Queen to C7 continuing development
Knight captures and C6 with have b d
captures and C6 and now Pawn to E5 and
this is a beautiful move uh that will s
sort of haunt Gish for the rest of the
game the The Pawn of course cannot be
captured if you capture the pawn the
idea is Rook captures on E5 and if Queen
captures there's Bishop captures on C6
check picking up the Rook on A8 at the
end of that line and you don't have
Queen to E1 Checkmate as the queen has a
retreat square the df1 square so after
E5 gkas just continues development
Bishop to B7 and now Knight to D2 again
uh seems like it's possible to capture
on E5 now as the the The Rook can no
longer be attacked but not really here
if you play Knight captures an E5 then
the idea is Queen G3 attacking the
Knight then the Knight cannot move as
the queen on C7 hangs so you have to
play F6 and now Pawn to F4 and after the
Knight moves you capture on E6 again
with a better position for uh for white
so after Knight to D2 We have Bishop to
E7 and now Bishop back to C2 putting
some pressure on this diagonal here so
if you castle and move the Knight you
might get checkmated so Pawn to C5 Gish
opens up his light Square bishop and now
Knight to F3 we have Rook to d8
attacking the queen and now Queen to E2
and here Queen to C6 putting pressure on
this long diagonal so now if this Knight
moves then Michael is the one getting
checkmate
and here uh how do you go about the
position the the the idea is if you play
something like Bishop to D3 and go after
the A6 Pawn which is certainly White's
uh plan at some point then Knight to H4
can be very unpleasant because Knight
captures an F3 will come with check
let's say Bishop captures on A6 You'll
Play Knight captures on F3 with check
now you can't capture with the queen you
have to capture with the G Pawn you mess
up White's Pawn structure and then you
capture on A6 let's say queen captures
and queen captures on F3 uh does look
very good for black so by playing King
to F1 you avoided this tricky line of
Knight captures and F3 Landing with
check so King to D7 Gish says all right
I'm not castling King side you have your
Bishops here attacking I'm just going to
shift my king over to the over to the
queen side sort of a a tigran petan like
Castle so Bishop to D3 going after the
pawn Here and Now Knights to H4 is not
as impressive because like we said if
Bishop captures an A6 you can simply
capture and attack the White Queen this
does not come with check and and if
Queen captures on A6 you'll capture on
F3 first and now you have Queen back to
D3 check you don't have to ruin your
Pawn structure or rather you will but
you will get to trade Queens at least so
for example captures and captures and
this is definitely a possibility uh but
he did not go for that uh he decided to
go for Pawn to B5 we have Queen to C2 uh
and now we have King to C7 continuing
with the advancement of the king to the
queen side Bishop to E4 attacking the
queen and queen to D7
uh Pawn to A4 they're trying to open up
the position to get the Rook to A7 and
attack the black king Bishop captures an
E4 we have Queen captures and now Queen
D5 Gish wants to trade Queens Michael
says nope not yet Queen E2 now
threatening to capture on B5 and now
Gish plays Queen to D3 so okay you can't
really keep avoiding the trade anymore
Queen captures Rook captures and now a
captures on
B5 a captures and now well you could go
for Rook to A7 check King B6 forces The
Rook back as The Rook still as the
bishop still hasn't been developed for
you to double up on the a file so first
we have Bishop to E3 by Michael and now
Rook to B8 by Gish uh so now you can
block even with Rook to B7 and now Rook
to A5 putting pressure on the Queens
side pawns we have Rook to D5 and now uh
Rook uh e to A1 doubling up on the a
file we have Rook to B7 by Gish or if
you go for Knight captures on E5 now
which still is not possible because uh
uh first you will capture here uh that's
the the better way to do it and after
Rook captures now you can either go for
Bishop to F4 which secures pretty much
everything here or you can even give a
nice check and after the king moves you
can still play this as the Rooks are on
the same diagonal so Rook to B7 stopping
Rook A7 check and now gush play Sorry
Michael plays Rook to A8 grabbing hold
of the back Rank and now you can go
after that G7 pawn and there doesn't
seem to be a way to defend it okay you
can play Bishop to f8 but it's not a
great Square for the bishop as the
Knight will get kicked away so you're
not going to going to be able to uh to
maintain such a structure so Knight to
f8 was played blocking this and now we
have Bishop to G5 by Michael uh also
I've allowed the engine to Crunch the
numbers here to like depth 45 and the
the engine says that black has really
nothing to do here the Knight f8 is a
suboptimal move and you should just
start improving the position of your
king as there's not all that much to do
for black if Rook B8 then you go for
Rook to A7 with check and uh it's just
going to be a very passive position for
black but here Michael played Bishop to
G5 he wants to go after the bishop so
Knight to G6 defending the bishop and
now he just trades Bishop captures
Knight captures and Rook to f8 going
after the F7 Pawn uh Gish says all right
Knight to G6 at least now I can capture
on E5 your U Bishop is now gone but
Michael does not capture on F7 if he
captured on F7 that would require him to
trade Rooks and if he trades Rooks uh
how do you continue this you go let's
say Rook E1 you defend the pawn Knight
to F4 going after the B2 pawn and now
let's G3 Knight to D3 Rook to E2 you can
play this but it doesn't look like
there's all that much um lukish is down
upon Pawn but his pieces are much more
active so instead he goes for Rook to G8
he goes after the G7 Pawn instead King
to B6 and now Rook captures on G7 so now
Michael wins a pawn and uh he will try
to prove that it's possible to hold it
now do capture on E5 now not the best as
um uh it's okay you can play Knight
captures on E5 but then Knight captures
Rook captures Rook captures on H7 and
you're only down one Pawn but the past H
Pawn will be very strong and very hard
to stop uh so instead uh Gish plays Pawn
to H5 he doesn't allow the capture on H7
and now Rook to E1 just defending the E5
Pawn Knight to F4 and go of course going
for that B2 pawn and now Pawn to G3
Knight to D3 and Rook to E2 defending
the B2 pawn and now gush plays Rook to
A7 he wants to go after the B2 pawn and
start advancing his own queenside pawns
and uh interestingly the move that
everyone thought that Michael would play
and uh he he he never wants to go after
this Pawn it's really interesting he
just plays Pawn to H4 improves his
position he's going to capture it later
on and then maybe create a pass pawn and
the situation on the clock is pretty
pretty severe 8 minutes for Michael 6
minutes for gkes and they have to make
those um last two moves to reach time
control and be granted additional 30
minutes so here we have Pawn to C4 uh
and now Rook to H7 finally going after
the H5 pawn and gkes goes for Rook to d8
and this is uh not the cleanest way the
cleanest way is to actually play Rook to
A1 check I will show it because it's
very nice King to G2 and after Rook to
A2 going for the pawn now you have to be
really careful because if you play Rook
captures on F7 then B4 comes and
now uh you can run into all sorts of
trouble for example if you capture C3
already wins the game you cannot capture
otherwise your Rook hangs if you do
nothing then you can just capture here
promote promote it to to a queen uh not
going to be possible so what you would
have to do after Pawn to B4 is Knight to
D2 and then okay uh after Knight to D2
the game is played let's say captures
captures you will play King to C6 and
the game continues but with very good
play for gcash but after Rook to d8 he
gives Michael a chance but Michael does
not go for it as one more move has to be
made for time control to be reached he
played Rook to D2 uh but the move to
actually go for the kill was Knight to
G5 and now okay the F7 point is hanging
strongest for black is Knight to C1 okay
first you harass The Rook a little bit
Rook D1 Knight to D3 The Rook will move
all the way to B1 bit of a passive
square but you don't care you're just
going to capture here and after Rook to
f f guarding the F7 Pawn now you capture
on H5 and you've improved your uh
position immensely but after Rook to d8
Rook to D2 by Michael and now uh time
control has been reached for him and
gush also plays the strongest move Rook
to A2 okay you could play Rook to A1
check first to force the king away at to
E2 and then uh then play Rook to A2 but
he decided to go for Rook to A2 right
away and now time control has been
reached and Michael finally captures the
pawn on F7 rukes captures on B2 and now
Rook to E7 going after the pawn he will
capture it with check so Rook to B1
check first we have King to E2 and now
Rook to C1 andish goes after the pawn
this way but now Rook captures on E6 and
uh this is now uh very very tricky uh
just okay to show you uh this Rook to C1
again wasn't maybe the cleanest way B4
here uh and uh sorry was was the
cleanest way because if you go for B4
now then look at the C captures C3 uh
what do you do now it's uh very tricky
stuff for example Rook captures on E6
King to B5 Rook captures on D3 and now
Rook to B2 check you're down a down a
piece but your pass Pawn is marching
forward King E3 C2 and it will be uh
very hard to uh to stop this Pawn you
will have to play something like Rook
captures on d8 allow the queen into the
game and it's still a draw objectively
with perfect play but uh you know as I
always say everything is a draw with
perfect play let's say queen C2 check
Rook to D3 you will stop this but then
Queen E2 check you will block this queen
to C2 with check you will run away Rook
captures on B4 check King goes to G5
Queen captures on F2 and yes after some
like Rook to C3 The Rook will move you
will start advancing your opponent white
will have enough for a draw H but this
was definitely the way to go for gkes
after Rook to C1 now it's a bit
different Rook captures on E6 with check
King to C5 uh and now Knight to G5 again
Rook to H6 does seem to be the way to go
to uh remove the Rook from uh from
blocking your own past pawn and going
after this Pawn to create another not
just one but to create two more pass
pawns H but Michael just doesn't want to
this Pawn he goes for Knight to G G5
first we have Pawn to B4 now it's
actually not the best move now it sort
of loses Gish the game but both of them
are again very low on time so C captures
on B4 check King captures and now Knight
to F3 stopping any Rook to E1 check
action uh so Rook to C3 and now Rook to
B6 with check we have King to C5 and now
Rook to F6 the point of the check was to
move the Rook from D6 Square so you can
start advancing your E Pawn and here
Rook to E8 if you just go back then of
course Pawn starts marching forward so
King to uh so Rook to E8 not f8 Rook to
E8 was played Now Pawn to E6 Michael
starts advancing his past E Pawn Knight
to C1 check King to F1 and now Knight to
D3 and now uh it would seem that best
for Michael would be to put the King on
G2 and just win the end game he's up two
pawns but he sort of um got the cold
feet here he is playing the top seat of
the tournament G is's a very strong
player and he thought that the C Pawn
was a bit too dangerous and after uh
some rep repetition here they agreed to
a draw or rather it was a draw by
three-fold repetition and King D2 that's
a draw uh but uh it's interesting what
happens if you don't go for this draw if
you just continue playing the game uh
let's say ju just to give you an example
they drew the game and Michael continues
his lead in the tournament he's leading
by by half a point uh but how to
continue this game and how to win it
well you actually have to work for your
meal quite hard Rook F5 check King to B4
and now Rook to A2 you want to defend
your Pawn here but now it's time to also
stop um gish's Advanced C Pawn so Knight
to C1 going after the Rook The Rook will
move to E5 now threatening some checks
here Rook to D3 moving The Rook out of
the way here and Rook to F7 now going uh
behind the black King Pawn to C3 Knight
to E1 now attacking the rook and Rook to
D1 Rook to to B7 with check for example
King to C4 Rook to C7 with check King to
D4 and now Rook to E3 and you uh
basically resign here your Rook was
attacked on E5 you move it to E3 now
you're threatening to capture on C3
black cannot stop this even if you try
with something like A2 then just Rook to
D7 check picks up the Rook on D1 so the
position is completely winning for white
but you have to play a series of let's
say eight engine precise moves and then
you will be able to win there there are
some suboptimal lines that are also WI
for white but with little time on the
clock they were both maybe down to okay
I'm not going to tell you uh I'm not
going to lie to you I'm going to check
what was the situation on the clock so
yeah Michael had 4 minutes and 40
seconds uh Gish had 2 minutes and 20
seconds so while it was possible to play
Michael leading the tournament playing
against the top seed okay draw not the
not the most terrible Choice uh you know
if the situation in the tournament was
maybe different maybe he would go push
for the win but you know tomorrow is the
rest day why would he he didn't want to
risk it you know if if you lose such a
such a winning end game and then you
have a rest day then you're just going
to go crazy on that rest day so here he
will enjoy himself and you know return
after the rest day as the leader of the
tournament so for the moment uh uh the
tournament standings Adams leading with
three and a half out of five then four
people tied at three GES Hans nean M
Bartel and jel Mard with two and a half
am me tabatabai with two and two two out
of five Nikita and Andre voltin Luke
mcshain on one and a half and shz Royal
on one and a half so we'll see what
happens will Michael be able to uh
maintain this incredible play as he's
just he's just you know playing the
tournament like he's the top seat he he
decided yeah I'm going to go all out
here and um since he already faced Hans
Neeman uh gkes cannot count on Hans to
take away some points from Michael so it
will be it will have to be Gish when he
plays hunts in the final round of the
London chess classic that could decide
the the fate of the tournament and
possibly the fate of goues will he
qualify for the candidates tournament
20124 uh so that's the game and a little
bit of info regarding the uh regarding
the you know possible future that we are
all facing uh hope you enjoyed that I
would like to thank David gasparian Sig
wiel grogo and gnome the maximite chess
club and H Huga boy on Spotify for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day